hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels
heute geht es ein typisch schwäbisches
rezept ich werde nämlich zwiebelkuchen
machen sich vielleicht zwiebelkuchen das
ist doch gar nicht schwäbisch da gibt es
natürlich ganz viele verschiedene
rezepte
ich werde jetzt die schwäbische variante
machen extra für den morata freude dass
ich nämlich und der zwiebelkuchen passt
auch perfekt in die jahreszeit denn man
ist dann ganz gerne zu federweißer
federweißer ist noch kein fertiger weil
also da hat diese alkoholische gärung
bereits begonnen aber eben noch nicht
fertig und noch nicht gefiltert
ich werde jetzt erstmal den hefeteig
zubereitet und danach eben die füllung
für den hefeteig traurig 250 gramm ehlen
den halben würfel hefe zwei esslöffel
warmes wasser einen teelöffel zucker
einen teelöffel salz 150 milliliter
mädels und 50 g weiche butter
ich nehme ich zuerst einmal das wasser
und die hefe und die candie's darin
auflösen
da kommt der zufall mit dazu und dann
führe ich das ganze und lass es dann
aber erst mal fünf minuten stehen dass
so eine art vorteil entsteht müsst ihr
nicht könnt ihr machen dann geht der
teig später ein bisschen schneller auf
und ihr benötigt eben auch viel weniger
häfen als ihr könnt jetzt sogar die hefe
menge nochmal reduzieren
falls ihr vorteil macht und den tag
einfach länger gehen lassen
jetzt in ein paar minuten später sieht
die hilfe so aus das heißt sie hat so
kein böses blut blazing gebildet und
schon ein bisschen aufgegangen jetzt
könnt ihr alle zutaten in der
küchenmaschine geben aber wir können
natürlich auch einfach den teig mit den
händen verlängern
da kommt jetzt auch salz mit dazu die
hefe mischung und die mit teig verkneten
und
bis auf 30 grad also falten
küchenmaschine mit hitze funktion habt
können sich gerne mit hitze paket
ansonsten einfach ohne und jetzt gebe
ich da noch die butter mit und lasst den
hefeteig etwa sieben bis acht minuten
ganz geschmeidig nähten
der hefeteig isef gut durchgeknetet und
durch den hohen zuckeranteil ist auch
wirklich schön geschmeidig und klebt
auch wirklich gar nicht vor mich ihnen
zu einer kugel und gebe ihnen dann
wieder in die schüssel zurück wo zu
machen lasst ihn erstmal aufgehen
und jetzt kann ich in der zwischenzeit
aber schon mal die füllung vorbereiten
und für die kühlung habe ich dir zu
haben hier vorne
für den belag aurich 500 gramm geschälte
zwiebeln 30 g butter 1 esslöffel mehl
200 milliliter sahne etwas kreuzkümmel
gemahlen und ich habe 400 gramm rinder
schinken salz und pfeffer bei dem rinder
schinken ist es so da hat mir jetzt der
mode türkischen rinder schink
mitgebracht es verpasst das ist ein ganz
spezieller zu bereiten
denn da ist außen rum so eine paste wie
nennt sich schämen und die stinkt ganz
furchtbar nach knoblauch und wenn man
sie gegessen habt dann riecht man das
auch richtig aber schmeckt natürlich
richtig gut
ihr könnt natürlich aber auch einen
rinder schenken nehmen der ebene des
chairman außen rum ist oder nimmt
einfach speck also das ist eigentlich im
original kommt speck mit rein
aber da wir kein schweinefleisch essen
nehme ich eben jetzt diesen rinder
schenken
dekker jetzt erst mal zur seite und ich
kenne das schon mal die zwiebel nehmen
und den feine ringe schneiden
und das mache ich jetzt in der
küchenmaschine mit einem kleinen hof
können es natürlich aber auch mit einem
messer machen
dafür werde ich die zwiebeln jetzt
erstmal halbieren und dann hall bringen
schreiben
jetzt gebe ich die butter in eine heiße
pfanne
wer jetzt die zwiebeln hier erst mal
angebracht
o
jetzt werde ich liebe mein mittlerer
hitze etwa 10 minuten garen
dabei solltet ihr darauf achten dass sie
glasig werden aber nicht frauen werden
so sei jetzt die zwiebeln aus und da
kommt jetzt noch das mehl mit dazu und
wird für etwa einer minute mit gebraten
die zwiebeln sind jetzt soweit fertig
den herd habe ich jetzt ausgestellt und
die können da ist ein bisschen abkühlen
und jetzt kann ich hier schon mal die
zutaten verrühren und zwar die eier mit
der sahne
da kommt noch etwas kümmel mit dazu und
geht jetzt einfach so viel mit dazu wie
ihr mögt also manche wir gar keinen
kreuzkümmel aber ich finde passt hier
wirklich super mit dazu und jetzt auch
ordentlich salz und pfeffer den die
zwiebeln brauchen schon
die werden jetzt kurz miteinander
verrührt und da muss ich einfach schnell
abfahrten betrieben komplett abgekürzt
dann kurz zur seite und dann nehme ich
jetzt noch den rinden und schneit in
kleine würfel und mir das jetzt
vegetarisch haben wollt dann lasst den
schinken einfach weg
dem gebe ich jetzt hier mit in die
füllung und verrührt es ganz kurz
und jetzt muss ich einfach noch schnell
warten bis die zwiebeln abgekühlten der
hefeteig ist jetzt aufgegangen und jetzt
kann ich ihnen bereits formen und zwar
nehme ich jetzt dafür ein backblech habe
ich jetzt dieses pizza backblech das ist
perforiert und dann backt daher kuchen
dass man auch ein bisschen knusprig das
muss ich jetzt vorher nur ein bisschen
einfetten und da stelle ich jetzt den
bug ring drauf den habe ich jetzt auf
etwa 26 zentimeter durchmesser
eingestellt der muss jetzt nicht ein
gibt aber ich hätte den auch ein war
danach verletzte hefeteig nicht schön
dran und ein hefeteig form geht's
einfach mit den händen so ein bisschen
runter und zwar so groß dass ihr einen
etwa fünf zentimeter hohen rand formen
könnte dann hab ich den so zusammen und
kann ihn dann auch hier rein
transportieren
jetzt drücke den teig so ein bisschen an
den rand und nach unten an den boden
damit eben eine schöne form entsteht und
nicht das später diese rahmen füllung
eingießen kann
jetzt muss ich den teig aber nochmal
abdecken und für etwa 15 minuten
aufgehen lassen
das mache ich jetzt im backofen und zwar
habe ich dir auf 50 grad eingestellt
werden jetzt wieder ausmachen und dann
hat er später nur noch zu etwa 30 bis 40
grad
der hefeteig ist aufgegangen und falls
sie jetzt so unregelmäßig aufgegangen
ist müsst ihr den einfach mit den händen
so ein bisschen vorsichtig in die form
noch mal rein drücken
und jetzt kommen da die zwiebeln mit
drauf
die verteile ich jetzt darin ein
bisschen
und da gebe ich jetzt die sahnesoße
drüber
jetzt kommt der zwiebelkuchen in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad und
war für etwa 35 bis 40 minuten bis der
teig aus muss ein bisschen goldbraun ist
der zwiebelkuchen ist jetzt gebacken und
ja wir noch abkühlen lassen und jetzt
werde ich ihn aufschneiden und wie
gesagt so wird man da am besten dazu
federweißer das ist so richtig deftige
richtig ich muss erst mal hört ziege
kuchen denkt stand eigentlich an
restsüße geworden und haben uns wieder
und es klingt sehr unappetitlich arbeit
ist es wirklich so ist die gefahr
flammkuchen und sowas in der art von
flammkuchen als ich habe ihr laufen
haben probleme zu zweimal
der boden ist bisher knusprig und ja
dieses passt immer dieses finde das muss
ich euch wirklich mal als marillion so
eine typische ladenraum machen oder so
was er durch den typischen supermarkt
und dann also so sieht es jetzt aus
hier unten ganz schön den hefeteig der
schön kross gebacken in diesen
backformen und dann darauf diese schicht
für schicht mit sahne und zwiebeln
er ist mit kamera ich glaube ist lecker
aus die ela wird gerne reinbeißen und
habt ihr noch garten apfelschorle
hingestellt wirklich super g klasse ich
hab mir mal 14 sahen zum ersten mal als
ich hab den zwiebelkuchen zum ersten mal
gemacht und ich meine man fast 50
prozent aller videos machst du zum
ersten mal probiert chamonix aber so
wahrscheinlich schon geschmeckt ja ein
echter wahnsinn jetzt wirklich
geschmeckt wirklich genial dass freud
west aber manche sachen standard
hefeteig kam einst nichts falsch machen
und war
erfüllung eigentlich auch nicht
beispiele auch bei schmidt muss mich
noch war ja ich habe jetzt gesagt
wirklich eigentlich was komplett
abkühlen lassen
aber lauwarm schmeckt da denke ich am
besten versatz zu drehen
nein aber dass das leicht süße süße
genau das leicht süße kommt durch die
zwiebeln die wir angefangen haben die
ambergerin süßlich ich habe auch vorher
lief die kamera habe ich erzählt dieser
mag eigentlich gar nichts was mit
zwiebeln zu tun hat aber sie liebt
zwiebel t das heißt immer wenn sie
husten hat und sagt immer mal wieder
zwiebel t weil wenn man die zwiebeln
auftauchten durchstarten werden die
einfach sehr süß und schmecken wirklich
eigentlich kaum noch nach zwiebeln daher
kommt jetzt auch die süße und dann wird
es eben unterstützt durch die sahne und
gibt sorgen die zwiebeln muss so süßen
bett ich finde die jule schmitt nicht
lecker es ist ein bisschen weniger süßes
fleisch
danach stand mit saurer sahne also ich
würde ganz ehrlich ich mach dich dumm
macht sony macht mit saurer sahne ja da
haben also alles super aber genau so ein
tipp von murat mit saurer sahne und ja
weil sie dieses rezept nach machen wollt
dann geht auch sally blog.de
da steht man mal für euch und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und du bekommst nachschub
habe ich das richtig verstanden und ich
nehme jetzt auch ein stück also
fußballspielen vergessen machen kein
passt immer der speck rein
wir haben pastor immer genommen oder
normalen rinder schinken oder man lässt
wenn es vegetarisch haben möchte oder
puten schinken oder tops bis dahin
tschüss